The Waimakariri district is now in a restricted
fire season.
This means that no fires in the open air can
be lit without a permit
and the season extends until further notice.
These restrictions apply to all fires on the
beaches and includes the lighting of fireworks,
use of outdoor braziers and chimineas.
Burning rubbish in drums is also restricted,
unless the drum is fully enclosed
and fitted with a flue.
Charcoal BBQ's are considered fires in the
open and are restricted.
However gas BBQ's and pizza ovens fitted with
flues are fine to use.
When applying to the Waimakariri District
Council for a permit,
it can take up to five days to carry out a site inspection and process  the permit.
So apply early.
And once you have a permit, any conditions
printed on it, must be observed.
Make sure you check out the safety tips in
the video linked below.
So remember, no open air fires without a permit.
And as always, think before you light.